do you like bartending it's not really
what I do what is it that you really do
[Music]
you came along and gave me these
unexpected
magical moment
that made me remember who I really was
hello hello how are you please tell me
you like the movie oh my gosh I had so
much fun I felt like a third wheel I
loved watching the two of you being a
fly on the wall it was so much fun the
opening scene between the two of you you
know what I loved about it is I felt
like I watched a scene with actors that
were speaking dialogue but then I
realized later there was no dialogue
spoken it was true body language so I'm
wondering what was like for you as
actors to communicate with each other
essentially without words
you are brilliant that was the purpose
of this scene it it had a story
it it it had an arc
yeah
it it it's to people that get
transformed through it there are in a
deep in the same situation in different
ways and at Cross Roads
in their own respective lives and
that happens in that dance it's it's a
we tell our stories and we connect in
the places that we need to connect
because in some ways we're similar and
we free ourselves and experience
something that we were not expecting and
come on the other side
it's so true
um Channing
um and and also you Selma what was their
inner dialogue if we could have heard
what they were actually saying in their
minds what were they saying I was saying
please don't drop some high on on her
head uh please just don't drop her
please just don't you know I was
thinking of nothing because it's it's
actually I was surprised when I saw it
oh I remember that I don't remember that
because it's like a meditation where you
have to be just present
and connected to to to to the music
to the rhythm of the other person so I
was not thinking of any dialogue well um
if you can sort of break down how you
shot it because it felt like what we
call in Hollywood a runner it felt like
it was one continuous shot I only saw
one break so can you talk a little bit
about how you two shot it did it was
there a lot of choreography all at once
did it feel that challenging sort of
break down that scene for us he didn't
cover it a lot so you had to it's like
one take or the other there was not any
places for me not a lot of places for
mistakes yeah Stephen doesn't shoot
traditionally he doesn't shoot like with
coverages he goes we're going to do this
section from this angle and then you do
that section from that angle and then
you move on to the next section and then
he shoots it in the exact way and also
he moves the camera so the timing it's
it's has to be perfect because every
angle is he the camera never stops
moving so you got to get it right it
felt like that the camera was dancing
along with you so that's with the fact
that you go girl you I love you you're
smart
oh my gosh you're my queen so okay from
you
um Channing is it ever really the last
dance I'm going to give you a little pun
is Magic Mike dropping the mic or is
there you're saying there's a chance
there's going to be another dance
I I think I'm Gonna Keep dancing but uh
I don't know if I'm gonna
Mike Mike's uh
I'm just gonna graduate in my life
done Mike's Mike's over yes but I feel
like we want to see his story I mean
forget you don't have to do the nobody
cares about the story I do I'm invested
in it
well now in this movie I think for the
very first time they will because we had
a female swords
but every single the both the two movies
before you know we got from everybody
was just like less less story less
character Just Dance more and and like
that's why we changed uh the formula and
and actually put a female's perspective
into it you did the opposite of what
they asked you yes yes it's good for you
I like that